[Music]
all right let's go to uh rich in chicago
hey rich what's up man
hey dr d what's going on we're man we're
getting through dude how about you man
i'm just gonna say that uh eggs at the
store are about a dollar a dozen i'm
just saying
i know but if i raise the chickens
myself they're about 111 a dozen right
yeah if you start doing the math on that
stuff it does not work out in the
preparation
so it's ridiculous
but it is cool and it's also
got to walk through grief with my son
and anyway so it is what it is man how
about you brother how can i help man
well um i'll get a little brief history
um i'm an alcoholic i've been in
recovery now for
for quite a while i've been in recovery
since 2007
working a 12-step program
part of
what we do in the program is it's one
alcoholic working with another
that seems to work where other things
fail
and so we we call it sponsorship and
it's um
it's kind of an integral part of
both sides
my recovery and the guys that i sponsor
and
i have a sponsor and i have a grand
sponsor and it just goes on and on um so
we've kind of built up this community
paul you've been sober in this program
i've been sober uh just under 14 years
be 14 years into the month
if if i survive yeah can we congratulate
you man can i just stop and say i'm
proud of you
thank you that's that's tough man that's
a long ride congratulations man
i burned down uh
burned down our uh
our finances in our relationship uh 14
years ago and
said no more huh
stood there in the ashes and my wife
took my hand we looked at each other's
eyes and said we were going to be okay
and
started that process and uh
it's uh so far so good so far so good
brother
um
to call you a hero would be undermining
the mission you and work you've done and
your wife too and so congratulations to
you man all right
he brought hey he brought me to god and
god brought me to aaa and that's just
kind of what it looks like it's awesome
so good for you brother
all right so i interrupted you yes so
we're you got to sponsor a grand sponsor
you're sponsoring
and what brought you here today man
well um
a guy came into the program about 10
years ago
um saw him struggling he'd go out two
years sober relapse two years over
relapse
about four years ago he approached me
and wanted me to to help him and so i
began sponsoring him and if you're
familiar with the steps we go through a
process where
they they pretty much dump everything on
us i mean they they go through a process
of inventory and and uh they lay it all
out on the table and we go through it
with them and
so basically i know more about the guy
than than anybody on the planet by the
time we're through with that process if
he works it the way he's supposed to and
this guy this guy did i'm pretty
confident he did yeah um
about three weeks ago this guy took his
own life ah man i'm sorry dude damn dude
yeah and uh
well it's just got you know it's
obviously knocked the wind out of my
sails i mean i've got a good community
around me i got good friends in and out
of the program
you know we're working through it it's
still raw it's three weeks out but uh
and i get that part you know and i also
get the part where
i don't have any control over the guy i
don't have any control over what's in
his head and any of that stuff
he uh
the way we worked what worked for him
um
we communicated daily
so we were tight i mean we were pretty
close
and
so
we communicated on a wednesday
um
he didn't call thursday didn't call
friday and i got a phone call from his
daughter saturday morning
no no no outside indicators nothing
that was obvious to anybody now i know
that he did suffer from depression he
did have some anxiety issues and i know
he was seeing a professional about that
he was working on a program outside of
ours obviously
this is going to sound um go ahead go
ahead
no no i'm sorry no you go ahead go ahead
um
so what i'm dealing with now
is
what am i doing
yeah this this whole sponsorship thing
it's got me
it's i'm back on my heels here i
i just
i
i kind of shudder at the thought of
picking up another spot to eat i mean
i'm not a i'm not a psychologist i'm not
a professional i i don't you know we
don't deal with mental health issues
i'm just a drunk trying to help another
drunk yeah and
when i'm faced with
this kind of thing you know and my my
grand sponsor took me aside and
we were at the visitation and
he said you can't take this personal
and i i get the sentiment
but
it's flipping personal
yeah it's real personal man
real personal
so your sponsor is trying to love you
the best he can and
um
but this is personal and trying not to
take it personal is insane
okay yeah this is as personal as it gets
i want you to take this person i want
you to let it sit in your heart this
this hurts okay
um
and first and foremost dude um there's
i'm sorry i've been there i've done too
many memorial services for people i love
um and i've said i'm sorry
um
have you wept yet have you sat in this
yet
oh yeah okay all right good oh yeah i um
i uh
his daughter asked me to do the eulogy
at the funeral and
you know when i went through that
process it was it was it was pretty
cathartic for me i mean it was it was
cleansing for me i was able to get past
a lot of stuff just by writing that
thing yeah and getting up in front of
the crowd and and saying it out loud
that
that helped me a lot um
and like i said i've got i've got
super close friends in and out of the
program i've got a couple of buddies
that um i call them my 2 a.m friends
they're the guys that you call them no
matter what time of night they're in
your driveway that's right that's right
um
i've talked through all this with with
those guys
obviously through the community in the
program
um lots of support there yeah but i
think i think
i'm good yeah um
but there's that there's that underlying
kind of guilt thing yeah there you go um
i've gone through the whole grieving
situation you know where i was sad and i
was upset and i was and then i got angry
you know why the hell didn't he call me
um that kind of thing
yeah now you're in that futile wasteland
yeah you're back in ash and you've been
in ashes before right yeah
yep
so there's a difference between
not taking this personal which you
should
and blaming yourself
and those are two
vastly different
feelings and processes
okay
there's no way in three weeks you've
cycled through everything you'll be
cycling through stuff for a long time
okay and they'll cycle quick you'll be
pissed off then you'll cry and then
you'll miss him and then you'll be
laughing
and so think of it as tight circles and
the circles get bigger and they get
bigger and you'll go through a longer
season where you're raged out against
this guy
because he's going to screw up your
weekends he's going to script like
there's a you know i mean it's hard you
get pissed off at him even though you
know it's stupid to get pissed off at
him and that he was hurting and anne um
and then you will have this just
scorched earth where you feel like
you're walking on it in a desert with no
trees no water no nothing
and you'll loop back and you'll look
back but
the difference between taking it
personal being heartbroken and blaming
yourself those are different do you get
the difference of those
i think that's probably the problem i'm
having is they're kind of overlapping
okay all right
they're kind of infringing on each other
and i think that's
that's kind of what i'm dealing with is
i so a lot of times when you especially
when you work a process when you work a
program
there's a there's a reason behind every
feeling every feeling is connected to a
thought and every thought is connected
to an action does that make sense
that's that's the beauty of the steps
where this gets out of whack is in the
depth of grief
external grief right so they give you
the 12 steps so that this thing never
happens again
and the challenge to that is
underneath you things happen
right and so the steps give you a level
of control that a drunk or a drug addict
or a sex addict don't normally have or a
food addict or whatever it gives them
control over them
where it's challenged it can feel like
it's a whole thing's unwound like you're
experiencing right now when's when a
meteorite hits you and that's what
happened because you can't control for
that right and so it makes you think
well why am i even doing these steps
these are stupid they're dumb they don't
even protect me from filling the blank
and the hard part is hanging on to what
you know works
and at the same time
going uh this happened right that's the
difference between blame and so the
steps work man they've you're sober for
14 years
and the past has
given you relationships 2 am friends
it's given you a model for what
friendship looks like and connection
looks like and my guess is you're a
better husband and a better dad a better
community member and all those things
and this just hurts
they're both and and sometimes step
programs don't do both and very well it
does either or really well
right
and so it's being able to sit and say
this hurts
and not my fault
i was this guy's go-to and
he did this
and not linking the two things together
and it's hard and this is where
journaling is really important because
you can separate those two this is when
writing him letters writing yourself
letters
in
too rich dear rich not i i
but dear rich
this happened and i'm sorry how would
you talk to somebody who called you how
would you call to another sponsor who
had their own sponsor how would you be
coaching them right now
you'd be saying brother it's not your
fault
all right this hurts and i'm gonna hug
you and we're gonna go hang out we're
gonna go the batting cages or whatever
but you didn't do this
right and so that's that hard balance
that hard gap
um real quick
and i know this is gonna sound
gratuitous and it's not how did he take
his life
uh he used a gun okay was he intoxicated
yes okay
um
do you remember back when you were drunk
and you did dumb things you did things
that you normally you look back and go
whoa
you remember those times
oh yeah
of course yeah and so what i want you to
do like you spent 14 years learning how
to forgive yourself right and how to be
graceful to yourself
eventually
you're gonna come to look at this man
that you loved and that you considered a
brother probably closer than your real
brother if you have one
no who
was connected to other people but could
never overcome that loneliness that
addicts experience
could never get that failure to belong
and then worse
he thought for whatever reason
especially when he was drunk or
especially when he was low
that he was going to be a burden to you
and he didn't call right
right
and
i would say that's a choice he made it
man he was intoxicated he died by
suicide man suicide took his soul from
him
and so all that to say at some point
you'll forgive him you'll make peace
with him and
this will in time make you a
not only world class it will make you a
gift of a sponsor to everybody around
you
because now i've sat through so many of
these things i'll look people in the eye
and smile and say i'm not letting this
happen to you i'll call in the calvary
on you i'll call ever does that make
sense it's made me
better at being a neighbor
having gone through these things i
wouldn't do it again over a million
years
but over time you end up making meaning
out of these things but that's not for
right now right now it's just for saying
sucks
does that make sense
yeah it does it does um
you know i think it i i can tell myself
this and i can listen to my sponsors and
i can listen to people in the program
and that's it's all good and i get it i
i totally get it and everything that you
said i get it it's not about getting it
it's not about getting it it's about
sitting in it
the getting it part is don't go drink
the getting it part is don't throw
everything away
because this happened
that happening doesn't mean that the
last 15 years of your life have been a
lie
this mean this what happened meant that
somebody wasn't well and they died by
suicide
you didn't fail brother
you didn't screw up
it's it's it's
it's hard not to tell myself that i know
dude i understand i know it is um
and you're in the middle of it okay
you're in the middle of it
it's you're you're
you have little kids you have kids i do
okay
think back to the first time you took
one of your kids to the pool
and they're on a diving board and you're
waiting you're treading water out there
trying to get them to jump and they're
on the edge of that diving board and
they're getting closer and closer but
they just won't go and they bend their
knees and they lean over but they don't
jump they don't jump
and then finally they jump
and then they're in that air and it
feels like a hundred years they're in
that air where they're falling and
falling and falling finally they hit the
water and the dad's there to get him
you just jumped
you're in the air and people can tell
you hey there's somebody at the butt it
doesn't none of that matters because
you're falling okay
what i'll tell you is you're surrounded
by people who love you
who are there in the water to catch you
when you hit
this is not your fault man
and you can tell yourself that all day
great
i want you to get it out of your head
and want you to start writing it down
okay i want you to spend some time
writing it down i want you to journal
about it and i want you to write letters
to two people two rich
and to your old friend
okay
and in those letters i want you to be
honest with rich i want you to be honest
with those with
your friend
and
be heartbroken be pissed off be angry
and exhale and get up and go again don't
throw this all away because of that
got it
we same team on that one
yeah i can do that i got your word
you're gonna stay sober
oh yeah okay
oh yeah you're in this for the long haul
brother we're in this with you you
you're doing everything right just
you're falling just sucks
okay oh man
i've been there been there been there
i'm having to take a deep breath too man
you'll hit the water and you're safe you
got people around you hang in there man
hang in there this is not your fault
brother